Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you’re watching
the TodayIFoundOut youtube channel, in the
video today, we’re looking at why Take Me
Out to the Ballgame is sung during the 7th
inning stretch of major league baseball games
and when the practice of a 7th inning stretch
got started.
Just before we get started today, I’d like
to call your attention to a relatively new
channel by one of our most prolific authors,
Karl Smallwood.
Karl’s new channel, linked in the description
below, is called FactFiend and is essentially
an interesting fact channel, but in a quite
different style than we do here, or really
anyone does as far as I’m aware.
Please do check his channel out and if you
like it don’t forget to subscribe.
And now without further ado, our video on
Take Me Out to the Ballgame.
You might be surprised to learn that this
staple of Major League Baseball games is actually
something of a modern practice, first starting
as a regular part of the seventh inning stretch
with the White Sox in the late 1970s, thanks
to Hall of Fame broadcaster Harry Carabina,
better known as Harry Caray.
Before this, the song had occasionally been
sung by fans at various baseball games (both
amateur and in the Major Leagues), but never
as a regular thing nor at any designated time.
The first known instance of this was at a
Los Angeles high school game in 1934.
It was also played before one of the games
in the 1934 World Series when Pepper Martin
and the St. Louis Cardinals Band played it.
Harry Caray started singing the song during
the seventh inning stretch in 1971, with fans
within earshot of his booth occasionally joining
in.
There are conflicting accounts from those
involved (including a story that changed over
time from then owner, Bill Veeck) as to how
this event transitioned to a White Sox tradition.
In one account, after Caray refused to sing
over the stadium PA system, Veeck tricked
Caray by switching on Caray’s microphone
while he was singing.
Probably, the more likely tale is another
first-hand account that it was all planned
out ahead of time.
But that’s not nearly as entertaining, so
one can see why the colorful Bill Veeck might
embellish the story a little.
Whatever the case, in 1976, Caray started
singing the song over the stadium PA system
and it became a local tradition.
When Caray switched to calling games for the
Cubs in 1982, he brought this tradition with
him.
Thanks to the fact that WGN broadcasted the
Cubs games nationally, the masses quickly
learned of Harry Caray’s seventh inning
tradition.
Shortly thereafter, variations on this tradition
were adopted at other stadiums, with the song
in question varying from team to team.
In the end, all teams went ahead and went
with Take Me Out to the Ballgame.
Despite the fact that singing Take Me Out
to the Ballgame during the seventh inning
stretch is a modern practice, the song itself,
about a girl named Katie Case who wants her
boyfriend to take her to a baseball game,
has been around since 1908 when it was written
by famed song writer Jack Norworth (who wrote
over 2,500 songs in his lifetime, including
a couple dozen that sold more than a million
copies each).
The music was composed by Albert Von Tilzer.
Funny enough, both of these gentlemen had
never actually been to a professional baseball
game when they created the song.
Norworth claimed the first Major League Baseball
game he ever went to wasn’t until June 27,
1940, a Dodgers / Cubs game.
So what inspired this non-baseball fan to
write a baseball song?
While riding a train to Manhattan, Norworth
said he saw a sign that said “Baseball Today
– Polo Grounds” and simply decided to
write a song about going to a baseball game,
so he scribbled it down during his ride.
Once the song was complete, Norworth’s wife,
singer-actress Nora Bayes, was the first to
sing it publicly.
It quickly became a hit at various vaudeville
acts and then beyond, becoming one of the
most popular songs of 1908.
BONUS FACT
You’ll often read that the seventh inning
stretch tradition in baseball was thanks to
President William Howard Taft in 1910.
The general story goes that the extremely
overweight President, after throwing out the
first pitch on April 14, 1910, in a game between
the Washington Senators and the Philadelphia
Athletics, was uncomfortable sitting in the
small stadium seating and by the seventh inning
needed to stretch, so he stood up.
When he did this, those in attendance noticed
and everyone else stood up out of respect
until Taft finally sat back down after thoroughly
stretching.
Whether this actually happened or not, we
do know that this was not the origin of the
seventh inning stretch.
The first recorded instance of the seventh
inning stretch goes all the way back to the
earliest days of professional baseball in
1869, where Harry Wright, who played for the
Cincinnati Red Stockings at the time, wrote
in a letter, “The spectators all arise between
halves of the seventh inning, extend their
legs and arms, and sometimes walk about.
In so doing, they enjoy the relief afforded
by relaxation from a long posture upon hard
benches.”
There are also other documented instances
of the practice of the seventh inning stretch
in both professional and amateur games before
Taft.
So while it’s true that Taft did indeed
throw out the first pitch of the game in question,
and given the seventh inning stretch was already
around, I’m even willing to buy that he
stood up and stretched at the appointed time.
But, it would seem the reason the masses stood
too was simply because this was already an
established practice.
That being said, it wasn’t specifically
called the “seventh-inning stretch” until
the 1920s.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below,
it really helps us out a lot.
Also don’t forget to check out Karl’s
channel, FactFiend, linked in the description.
And thank you for watching.